i
[Aplausos]
cuando fue la última vez que imprimieron
algo en papel
quizás un trabajo de la universidad o
quizás un informe laboral para la
oficina es algo que lo hacemos todos los
días
qué tal si yo te digo que puedo imprimir
que podemos imprimir
tus pulmones
tu corazón
tu oreja
o uno de tus huesos
probablemente les parezca algo futurista
algo
muy alejado la realidad algo lejano
déjenme contarles por qué no es tan
lejano
hace 4 años durante mis estudios de
doctorado en bioingeniería conocí a una
niña llamada isabella
isabella
tiene cáncer un tipo de cáncer que se
llama osteosarcoma es un tumor que crece
muy cerca de las articulaciones y que
ataca principalmente a niñas ya jóvenes
isabella tenía un tumor creciendo en su
fémur muy cerca a su rodilla
para salvarla era necesario extraer ese
tumor y por lo tanto extraer una porción
del hueso y luego obviamente había que
poner un reemplazo en ese hueso
el problema con los implantes actuales
es que están muertos son inertes no
tienen vida y como tal van a van a
ocasionar que el hueso de isabela no
crezca alrededor de ese implante y con
el tiempo se va a aflojar y se puede
rechazar esto que significa que isabella
va a tener que entrar a varias cirugías
de revisión durante toda su vida lo cual
quiere decir padres preocupados
horas de quirófano y una niña que no
puede vivir su vida normal como
cualquier niña jugando o saliendo con
sus amigas
cuando cuando me presentaron el problema
de isabela yo me hice una pregunta
porque no podemos hacer implantes que
tengan vida
y para responder a esta pregunta tuve
que empezar a investigar sobre dos cosas
que de las cuales no sabía absolutamente
nada
una de estas cosas era la impresión 3d
probablemente tú hayas escuchado hablar
de impresión 3d y probablemente también
hayas visto una impresora 3d trabajando
pero qué es la impresión 3d o cómo
funciona la impresión 3d
todo empieza aquí en nuestra cabeza
donde surgen las ideas si tú quieres
crear algo lo dibujas en una computadora
en 3-d y luego lo tienes que introducir
a un software que lo que va a hacer es
traducir esta imagen traducir esta forma
tridimensional en un lenguaje que el
equipo va a entender y cómo lo va a ser
lo va a ser capa por capa va a ir
traduciendo lo capa por capa y la
impresora lo va a ir creando capa por
capa añadiendo una capa sobre otra por
eso se llama manufactura aditiva porque
al contrario de la manufactura
convencional en donde nosotros extraemos
material para crear algo aquí añadimos
material para crear algo la expresión 3d
ha venido a revolucionar la manera como
creamos las cosas como manufacturamos
las cosas como consumimos las cosas
porque podemos imprimir en tres de
comida
si se imprime comida en 3-d podemos
imprimir en tres de casas o edificios
y también se usa la impresión 3d en
medicina
porque la impresión 3d es el único
proceso de manufactura que nos permite
crear formas muy complejas y que hay más
complejo que los órganos de nuestro
cuerpo y allí voy a esa segunda cosa que
tuve que aprender o investigar para
resolver el problema de isabela porque
seamos sinceros yo soy un ingeniero y en
ese momento no sabía absolutamente nada
de medicina y tuve que empezar a
investigar específicamente sobre huesos
sobre tejido óseo los huesos son muy
particulares son mixtos exteriormente
tienen una forma muy dura un tejido que
se llama cortical y por dentro se ven
así es una forma aleatoria como una
caverna yo como ingeniero veo esta
imagen y pienso en una estructura como
en la estructura de un puente
ahora déjenme regresar a esa primera
pregunta que me hice porque no podemos
crear implantes con vida
básicamente por dos problemas
el primero es un problema de resistencia
en este momento yo estoy caminando y
cuando estoy caminando estoy ejerciendo
una fuerza sobre los huesos de mi cuerpo
lo cual es bueno es beneficioso los
implantes que se usan actualmente son
muy duros son de un material por ejemplo
como titanio y esto no es necesariamente
bueno porque cuando yo estoy haciendo
mis ejercicios por ejemplo ustedes
cuando salgan a correr y están
ejerciendo esa fuerza si tienen un
implante ahí es implante va a absorber
toda esa fuerza que estamos ejerciendo y
todo el hueso que está alrededor de ese
implante se va a debilitar no va a hacer
ejercicio y por lo tanto se va a
fracturar lo que quiere decir que los
implantes se van a aflojar
el segundo problema es un problema de
vascularización
qué vascularización básicamente permitir
que la sangre fluya a través de su
implante y como los implantes
tradicionales son inertes no permiten
vascularización
vamos a resolver estos problemas uno por
uno el primero el de resistencia y tengo
que regresar a esta imagen del hueso
trabecular cuando yo vi esta imagen
cuando yo vi a esta imagen yo pensé que
esta forma aleatoria no puede ser
producto del azar que tiene que tener
alguna acción en la resistencia del
hueso entonces lo que hicimos fue de la
una imagen médica de isabela hicimos una
reconstrucción
y de donde extraemos esa forma
trabecular del hueso no esa forma
trabecular del hueso que la pusimos en
nuestros implantes y creamos estos
implantes utilizando el único proceso de
manufactura que me va a permitir crear
lo que es impresión 3d porque es una
forma extremadamente compleja nosotros
pusimos estos implantes en ensayos de
resistencia y los comparamos con los
implantes comunes y el resultado fue que
en la misma dirección natural en donde
ejercemos fuerza en el hueso estos
implantes no fueron ni más ni menos
fuertes que el hueso humano sino similar
primer problema resuelto ahora vamos al
segundo problema ese problema de
vascularización cómo lo resolvemos lo
que hice fue crear un ambiente amigable
en el hueso para que se sienta lo
suficientemente cómodo como para crecer
alrededor del implante como lo hicimos
cogimos células del cuerpo de isabel a
células óseas y bañamos nuestros
implantes con esas células esperando que
esas células se adhieran al implante y
luego pusimos un cóctel químico para
excitar esas células y que produzcan
huesos
y este es el resultado lo que ustedes
están viendo a su lado izquierdo son las
células que están creciendo sobre
nuestro implante lo que ven en azul son
los núcleos de las células y lo que ven
en rojo es la matriz celular que está
expandiéndose por el implante y lo que
está en el lado derecho es lo que parece
de la rasgándose es hueso
es hueso que está creciendo sobre
nuestro implante
segundo problema resuelto hoy isabella
ya tiene dos años con nuestros implantes
sin entrar en cirugías de revisión
esta tecnología que abre la puerta para
una nueva generación de implantes me
hace pensar también que abre la puerta
para una nueva generación de órganos
bajo demanda
y yo me pregunto
puede ser acaso que esto signifique que
nosotros vamos a empezar a descuidar de
nuestro cuerpo porque vamos una persona
que es fumadora ya no va a tener excusa
para dejar de fumar porque va a tener un
par de pulmones disponibles para el bajo
demanda o quizás una persona que toma ya
no va a tener excusa para dejar de fumar
porque va a tener un hígado ahí
disponible para el bajo demanda
pero sinceramente yo creo que la puerta
que estamos abriendo con esta tecnología
es mucho más de esperanza es mucho más
es un futuro mucho más brillante y
promisorio porque gracias a esta
tecnología y gracias a estos implantes
nosotros podemos salvar vidas
y por qué no tu vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]